[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la Ligue nationale se fait une fierté de
soutenir la communauté LGBTQ plus depuis
quelques années on arbore des chandails
par la suite vendus aux enchères on met
sur pied des kiosques d'information on
donne une visibilité peu commune à la
diversité sexuelle dans le sport de haut
niveau mais cette saison nuage gris sur
l'arc-en-ciel
en janvier un joueur
Ivan provoc a invoqué des raisons
religieuses pour ne pas participer à
l'initiative l'histoire a fait grand
bruit après ce premier domino d'autres
sont tombés trois équipes ont annulé
leur soirée 6 joueurs ont refusé de
porter le chandail parmi eux Eric Storm
un ancien du Canadien
il l'avait porté à Montréal il y a deux
ans mais n'a pas voulu le mettre en
Floride store la même ni son soutien
passé
d'autres joueurs d'origine russe ont
plutôt évoqué des raisons de sécurité
ils se sont désistés par crainte de
représailles dans leur pays ou une loi
interdit la promotion de l'homosexualité
pour le président de l'Observatoire de
géopolitique de l'UQAM Yann roche
l'argument ne tient pas la route
l'infraction est généralement passible
d'une amende et très peu de gens n'ont
subi les conséquences selon lui une
excuse pour
cacher une certaine homophobie qui est
présente dans dans beaucoup de milieux
sportifs de haut niveau dont notamment
le hockey on commence à s'en douter de
manière très claire devant l'ampleur de
la controverse le meilleur joueur du
monde a fini par s'emmêler
un
hamiltonisation veut prendre l'organisme
commun aire grimonial qui sensibilise la
population aux enjeux LGBTQ plus pour
elle le portrait n'est pas si sombre
mais c'est que c'est bien de mettre
quand même je dirais le projecteur
surtout ceux qui le font mais ce sont
surtout les récalcitrants qui se
retrouvent sous les feux de la rampe un
point telle ou le commissaire de la LNH
remet maintenant question ces soirées
[Musique]
le Canadien présentera sa soirée en
soutien à la communauté lgbtq+ ce jeudi
moi j'aime tout le monde j'invite tout
le monde puis je suis content qu'on fait
ça en 1960
pour le moment ici Alexandre gascon
Radio-Canada à Montréal